if you ask a game developer how they
learned programming and design chances
are they'll tell you all about the work
they put in on their own time many of
them taught themselves how to code and
most of them learned little of game
development in the classroom but over
time those tools got better game maker
in Adobe Flash arose in the 90s and made
game development software more
accessible and somewhat easier to learn
more importantly however the Internet
has made the information on how to use
these engines much easier to find and
consume in addition several games give
users streamlined tools to learn a game
system design such as project spark and
hecka / kids can now even go to summer
camps to get the first exposure to
development with all of the new tools
there's a generation of kids that have
grown up learning how to play design and
program games from a very early age this
new trend in development brings us to
girls make games a three-week summer
camp for young girls who want to learn
how to program design and create games
the team members have been taught about
coding and design and they've been given
the opportunity to work with developers
come up with ideas and put those ideas
into action the girls of this camber
between 11 and 16 years old and they
represent the new wave of game
developers these girls will be growing
up with the knowledge of how to make
games and use them as places a personal
expression much like how kids are taught
in school from a young age to use
writing to communicate emotions and
thoughts now games are taking on a
similar role for children this is how we
get games like last year's winner of the
girls make games camp it launched on
Steam last week after being successfully
kick-started and this year five more
interesting and incredibly creative
games were competing for the top prize
the chance to be kick-started and
eventually be sold on Steam one of the
judges helping to decide which aim one
was Robin henneke but you might know as
the producer of journey from that game
company she explained that this camp
represents a new generation of game
developers who have learned to make
games earlier than ever before when I
started out it was pretty opaque it
wasn't really clear how do I get started
what programming language should i learn
maybe i have to learn c++ from scratch
or c and now you can go in there you can
start up with unity and do a little bit
of editor script and suddenly hey you
have something on screen it's much
easier to get started but also and this
is the thing that I think is really
revolutionary is that we can share our
ideas and we can funder ideas
internet with crowdsourcing crowdfunding
you can end up in a situation where you
have assets at your disposal and money
at your disposal and a whole audience
following you just because you clicked a
button which i think is really fantastic
when I started it was a little bit
different I think it's super compelling
to think about what the world would be
like if everybody could take their
creative and interesting fantastical
ideas and turn them into something to
share with someone else right I mean
learning to express ourselves and share
our vision is what makes us understand
one another more and also it really
broadens the landscape of what games can
be about you know if you imagine what
the world would be like if everyone's
interior sort of was was shareable and
something that other people could see it
would probably be a more peaceful and
whole place so I really like the idea of
people being able to find that voice
especially young people because young
people are the future the barrier to
entry for game development has lowered
and the results are already obvious more
games than ever before are being
released on Steam mobile app stores and
even on consoles more kids are learning
how to make games even as they learn how
to play them kids are bringing their own
unique perspectives to game development
creating stories of vocativ of their own
personal experiences these new
developers exist outside the world of
focus groups and big publishers and they
make games because there simply
passionate about the menu games have
always been artistic but this surge in
game development has cemented them as an
art form like painting or poetry games
have become another way to communicate
with an audience and to achieve personal
expression the girls make games camp is
just one example of a new mindset that
game development is an acceptable
legitimate career and as a result these
kids are excited and encouraged to
continue making games they are a big new
generation of developers that will have
the skills and the desire to make games
by the time they become adults they're
developing games with the creativity of
youth and with the lessons they learn
early they'll be equipped to make
incredible projects later on I don't
know about you but to me that's the most
exciting thing in games right now
you